こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
今日の動画はですね
ちょっと真面目な話になるんですけども
（鼻をすする）
フフッｗｗ
いや、 真面目かどうかはわかんないです
それは皆さんがこの動画を見てから決めてください。
今回ですね、あのー
いつもお世話になっている 大家さんに
1つ、頼み事をしようと思いまして
この動画を撮っております。
その頼み事はなにかと言いますと、
ここ 今 はじめしゃちょーメインチャンネルの部屋ね。
はじめしゃちょーのメインは
この建物で撮っているんですけども
も、私、はじめしゃちょーの畑の方でも
出演しておりまして、
もう前も何回も言ってるんですよ！
行き来がめんどくさい！！↑↑
それも結構頻繁に編集とか撮影の影響で
結構行き来しててて本当に大変なんですよ。
もう一度おさらいします。まず玄関出ます…
こうやって歩いてぇー
は）ここ入んなきゃいけないんだよねぇ？
だ）はい、そうです。
は）で、こうやって行かないと、結局ダメなんですよ
あのー、僕が、メインチャンネルから畑に行く時。
は）大変なんですよ、いちいち。
だ）でしょう、ねぇ
なんか天井にハシゴとか掛けてやったんですけど
やっぱりめんどくさい
は）ねぇ？
や）えぇ、へっｗｗ
というわけでちょっと、
みんなに関わる話なんですけど、あの、
本当にもったいないというか、その、移動時間を
ゼロにすれば相当いいと思うんですよ、効率的に。
や）うん　　　　だ）まあ
真面目な話、あのー、私今から大家さんに
ドリルで壁に穴を開けていいか聞いてきます。
や）何を言ってんのｗｗ
だ）へへっ、ちょっと、それはｗｗ
は）本気なんです、僕はぁぁ！！
や）フフフフフｗｗｗ
だ）マジでｗｗ
は）本気なんです。　だ）まじすかｗ
は）真面目な話…してるんです
ほら、こうやってね、いちいち撮り戻す時もね、
こうやって戻らないといけない手間がかかって
本当にもう嫌だ
まぁ ああやってね、みんなヘラヘラ笑ってますけども
僕はいたって真面目な話をしています
この1号室と2号室の壁をぶち破れれば、
無限の可能性…
部屋自体も大きくなりますし、移動の時間もなくなる。
できることも増える
全てにおいて、僕、最強だと思ってまして、実は。
ただ結構、あのー
真面目な顔して言ってるんですけども、
相当、バカげたことを言っていると思うんですよ。
そもそも賃貸なんで、
壁を壊すっていうこと自体が御法度なんで、
まあ、普通に考えちゃやってはいけないですよ。
でもねー、
常識に捕らわれてちゃダメなんですよ！！！！(荒)
僕はこれまでもこれからも、
普通のことはしようと思ってません
常に普通の上のなにができるかを
考えて動いていますので。
ワンチャン、大家さんだったら、
「あー、いいよ」(大家さんのモノマネ)
って言ってくれるかもしれません
それはわかんない
また、不動産の関係で、
大家さん以外の誰かの許可を取ってからじゃないと
壁をぶち壊せないかもしれない
とりあえず僕はもう壁をぶち破りたいんですよ
1号室と2号室の。
皆さん想像してみてください。この壁をぶち壊したら、
未来が広がっているんですよ
結構ガチです、僕。ちなみに今からですね、大家さんのアポをもう取っていて、
今から大家さんに会いに行ってきます
あの、真面目な話をさせていただきますので。
果たして、賃貸の壁は
ぶち壊すことはできるかどうか、
大家さんにやっていいのかどうか
聞いてみたいと思います。
では、行ってみましょう
[ﾋﾟｭﾝﾋﾟｭﾝ]
はい、ちなみに建物的な話をしましょう
こちらが2号室
で、こちらが1号室です
こっちが畑
こっちがメインの建物となっております
で、僕、どこをどうしたいのかと言いますと、
まあ、この隙間にですよ
この隙間に壁があるんですよねー。それをドリルで
ぶち破れればいいなと思っております
では大家さんに聞いていきたいと思います
[ﾋﾟｭﾝﾋﾟｭﾝ]
は）失礼します！
大家）ああ、どうぞどうぞどうぞ
は）ふぅ〜〜〜…(息を吐く)
は）大家さん
大家）はい
は）最近元気ですか？
大家）ちょっと、体重の増加が気になります
は）あぁ、そうなんですね
大家）はい
は）私も今ダイエット中でして
大家）みたいですねぇ
は）まあ、そんな話はさておき、
大家）はい
は）今日ちょっと大家さんに
頼みごとがあって
参りました。
大家）はい。合法的なことであればなんでも。
は）あ、本当ですか
は）いや、とりあえず
は）可能か、不可能かだけを
ちょっと聞きたく存じておりまして
大家）はいっ
は）ズバリ 、言わせていただきます
大家）どうぞ
は）ふーーーーーっ(息を吐く)
は）えーっとですねぇ、
は）1号室と2号室の壁をぶち壊すことは
可能でしょうか？
大家）構造計算上、無理だと思います。
［通常ED］
は）やっぱそうなんですね
大家）そう、あそこで支えてる。
は）あー、壁が大黒柱になってるような
感じですかねー
大家）実を言うとそれは、数年前 僕も提案しましたｗ
は）あはっｗｗそうなんすか？ｗ
大家）はははっ
は）そうなんですかｗｗ
大家）そうｗ　は）へーｗ
は）構造上壁が厚いってことですよね
大家）そうです
は）大家さん、k r…無理ですか、壁は。
大家）無理です！
は）ドリルでちょっとこう…なんとか！
大家）こうなっちゃいます(涙)
ふふふっｗ
は）無理ですか！
大家）無理ですｗ
は）ちきしょぉぉぉぉぉーーー！！！！
[某カードゲームアニメ 次回予告音楽]
はじめによる女性風ナレーション）壁の破壊を
大家さんに止められてしまった、はじめ。
絶体絶命のはじめが苦肉の策に選んだ方法とは！？
諦めないで、はじめ！！
まだ勝負は終わってないわ！
次回！
「はじめ、無許可で壁をぶち壊す。」
デュエル、スタンバイ！！